Houston Texas where hospitals are
beginning to face dire conditions like
those in New York back in March I see
use our packed and beds are filling up
quickly new daily cases have nearly
tripled in Texas since the start of last
week alone Janet shamlian spoke to
frontline workers in Houston sorry if I
break down a little bit but it was bad
Tanya fields is a nurse in Amarillo
Texas
she says she was working at a nursing
home when she contracted Kovac 19 and it
almost killed her it's very scary for
for me and for my husband I just asked
him I just said you just let me die I
said I can't I can't go on any longer
with this Tonya and her husband Mac will
celebrate their first anniversary Monday
a day she wasn't sure she'd see the
entire time he kept telling me baby
you're not you can't die I can't lose
you I need you and that's what kept me
going Fields is recovered and will soon
be back at work this is the scene inside
Houston's Baylor st. Luke's Hospital
health care workers in full personal
protective equipment caring for the new
crush of kovat patients what are you
singing the emergency room right now we
are really overwhelmed right now in the
emergency department it's very busy
right now it's just extremely extremely
full of patients that are very sick from
kovat 19 dr. Gina blocker works in the
emergency room and says she's seeing an
alarming increase in minority patients
and we were seeing blacks and Latinos
affected at higher proportions
than we've seen in the beginning of this
when this illness pandemic started
statewide nearly 7,000 patients are
hospitalized in Texas with kovat 19 as
of Wednesday with 57 deaths ten days ago
that number was just under 4,000 with
ten deaths
doctors fear rising hospitalizations now
will soon lead to a spike in fatalities
Tonya fields returns to the frontlines
on Monday I'm terrified to go back to
work but I've just got to work through
it and be an advocate for my patients
and let you know so that I can be a
teacher to them as for dr. blocker who
works here at the Texas Medical Center
she says in a recent shift an eight-hour
shift she had to put five patients on a
ventilator there were that sick and she
says if you want to help first-line
responders wear a mask social distance
and save lives
Gayle boy thank you dr. blocker and
Tonya feels all the first-line
responders thank you very much Janet